it's so good to see you again i'm so
excited to see this one through to
release now too it's about time
it's been it's a different world before
kimono
when you were doing things in tights in
close places
i feel like i hold the sundance
experience near and dear now
because of it i keep uh looking back at
pictures and just trying to like relive
the moment
remember did you find that it was a
challenge getting your first feature
off the ground or did your other work
and your past accomplishments
give you the momentum that you needed to
have folks believe
that you could direct your first feature
i'd say that i spend
so much of my um time making films doing
kind of short films and commercials and
art
pieces and i would say that they didn't
particularly help
however before i did this film i did
tickle monster
which was a short narrative piece and
that really did help um
convince people that i can i can
shoot something bringing up tickle
monster it makes me want to ask you
about
what you like to do during the casting
process because you gotta
you got a great ensemble here and i'm
also a huge fan of rihann
so i don't know what are the pillars of
your process when it comes to filling
the roles and
how do you find such awesome people i
mean i i
wish like it was all down to me but we
had an amazing custom director carmen
cuba
who helped lead the car these lead the
casting i'm just fortunate that we find
such amazing
actors who are willing to
do crazy stuff to make something
lovely um so i'm very fortunate to have
found champagne with me
they're so good and i can't not ask you
about working with them
on set and maybe specifically what is
something
unique that each of them require from
you as an actor's director in order to
prep for a scene
oh show plays very methodological oh
a journal of notes and he would
really dig in he'd really ask me some
really tough questions and i'm like damn
i need to
i need to know what i've written and
that's really
that's a pleasure to work with someone
who really cares about what he's doing
and to talk things through with him and
so that's
something about him women i find
well me so good at she is so emotionally
intelligent
that she finds the emotional core of
anything and so if something
is written and she's not convinced that
it's emotionally truthful she will she
will tell you
and she will she will happily discuss
with you
better ways to tell a scene and
i'm very thankful for that that's uh
that's for me to back up a little here i
was curious about
the uh the writing process and
specifically about your collaboration
with felicity and
toby where did they come into the
equation and how did you guys work on
the screenplay together
when i was making commercials and arty
pieces acetone
i we used to have a product no we were
signed to production company who shed an
office with the two producers ed
martin of this film so every time i went
in i'd see them we talked about
me wanting to make features one day and
one day they said
we had this project um with felicity and
toby
about immigrants pretending the whole
story about the immigration
process in this country and
for whatever reasons i think they were
hitting a wall that it wasn't
going to it wasn't quite where they
wanted the script to be so they asked me
if i would pitch them my
version my take on it and so i
told them that i would make
my idea of having it being much more
psychological about two people
and how they
are processing their trauma and i guess
how to survive after surviving
and they liked it so i welcome and you
and you made the film was there any
particular element of that that you
could call maybe your break story moment
because there's
there's so much going on here the big
picture the tension in their
relationship
the the night which what was the thing
that kind of brought it all together for
you
we did so much research before writing
the
script and one of the things
that really are really found really rich
was in the in the
asylum process in this country they
would often
give someone the government often give
someone a
house to live in but by getting the
house you have to follow these really
draconian rules for example
you're not allowed to leave the house
you're not allowed to have a job
you're given a very small amount of
money weekly
and this seems such a um
cruel and cold way to treat people
who are trying to come to terms and of a
new home and
moving forwards and i guess their new
life and i felt like especially in the
in the whole genre in the haunted house
genre it seemed this seemed a
particularly rich scenario to be in when
you're forced into a house
that could be haunted but the
you're not able to get out
and that was i guess the moment that was
the colonel
the beginning of the story the film
you nailed that combo to wrap up here
now that his house is finally coming out
is there anything about your experience
making the movie that you think you're
going to take on to future projects
whether it's
finding uh similar themes or ideas you
want to keep exploring
trying new technical things anything at
all i really
enjoyed mining myself i said enjoy it is
not probably the right word i think it's
really important to really
dig deep in yourself and you're writing
something and i i hope
that i can continue doing that for my
future projects
i'm rooting for you and i believe it's
gonna happen thank you so much for your
time today and i think we're chatting
again soon